il porte le nom du compositeur préféré
d'Hitler
fondé et dirigé par evegaini Prigogine
le groupe paramilitaire russe Wagner
joue aujourd'hui un rôle important dans
la guerre en Ukraine loin de son terrain
de chasse favori qui est l'Afrique
[Musique]
Soudan Libye Tchad Guinée ou encore
Madagascar selon le Centre pour les
études stratégiques internationales ces
mercenaires sont aujourd'hui présents
dans une quinzaine de pays du continent
le modèle africain de Wagner est
désormais bien connu c'est la prédation
des ressources locales en échange de ses
services comme en Centrafrique et au
Mali ou le groupe a fait main basse sur
les mines d'or du pays à la clé une
immense manne financière un chiffrable
mais indispensable pour financer ses
opérations en Ukraine et bien payer ses
hommes
également présent en Syrie et au
Venezuela les mercenaires de Wagner sont
accusés dans plusieurs pays africains de
viol et de torture
depuis plusieurs mois le groupe est
monté en puissance en Ukraine tout comme
son chef fgny Prigogine très agacé par
l'état-major de l'armée russe pas à la
hauteur selon lui
trigogine le sait il perd chaque jour
beaucoup de notamment à barmut ou les
combats font rage depuis des mois avec
l'armée ukrainienne
impossible de connaître les effectifs de
Wagner car des dizaines de milliers de
détenus ont été recrutés en prison et
autant d'hommes selon les dires de son
chef sont morts sur le champ de bataille
les cimetières qui leur sont dédiés
comme celui-ci sont en tout cas de plus
en plus vaste
le groupe Wagner Vladimir Poutine en a
longtemps ni elle existence et réfute
encore aujourd'hui tout lien avec lui
en novembre dernier le groupe sort
définitivement de l'ombre et inaugure
s'est imposant bâtiment en plein cœur de
Saint-Pétersbourg ville ou Prigogine et
Poutine se sont connus
il abrite une autre activité de Wagner
sa propagande au service du Kremlin une
usine à troll qui emploie des milliers
de soldats numériques la seconde armée
d'eph gay ni Prigogine